- BLINK 182 OR 311?
- 311.
- 311'S A GOOD BAND.
- YEAH.
- HERE WE ARE
AT THE SCENE OF THE CRIME.
THIS IS WHERE I WAITED
FOR ANGEL AND MATTHEW.
THEY NEVER
SHOWED UP,
AND SO I SLICED UP
THOSE TIRES.
SLASH.
RETRIBUTION.
MY BOY ANGEL
DOES SOUND FOR ME.
HE DOES A BAD JOB
'CAUSE HE'S TOO BUSY
SMOKING METH ALL DAY.
I SAID, "ANGEL,
GET OFF THAT TINA.
GET YOUR ACT TOGETHER."
HE SAID, "NO, I'M GONNA DO
WHAT I DO."
I SAID,
"YOU LEAVE ME ALONE.
"I'M NOT GONNA
TAKE THIS TONIGHT.
"'CAUSE IF WE
GO IN THE AREA TONIGHT,
"WE GONNA HAVE FUN.
"AND I DON'T WANT TO
THINK ABOUT WORK
WHEN I'M NOT AT WORK."
AND ANGEL'S LIKE,
"NO, NO, NO.
I WORK FOR YOU.
I DON'T WORK FOR ANYBODY."
I SAID,
"YOU DON'T WORK FOR ME.
NOT ANYMORE."
YOU KNOW?
ISN'T THAT--
ISN'T THAT THE TRUTH
WHEN YOU WORK WITH FRIENDS?
- WHAT THIS IS?